So Donald Trump is the perennial victim.
According to him, right.
He is now retweeting the conspiracy theory
from former Love Connection host Chuck Woolery
that his own CDC is lying about Corona virus
in order to hurt Trump's chances at reelection.
Now, I don't know about you.
I'm sick and tired of Trump constantly being
the victim guy who's been wealthy his whole
life, was handed a business thanks to his
dad's money, is president of the U.S.
From his rhetoric, you would believe that
he was the biggest victim there is, except
he's the most privileged person there is.
And now there's a conspiracy theory which
was put on Twitter to start with by former
game show host Chuck Woolery.
Trump retweeted it.
And the way it goes is, quote, The most outrageous
lies are the ones about Kovik, 19.
Everyone is lying.
The CDC, media, Democrats, doctors, not all,
but most that we are told to trust.
I think it's all about the election and keeping
the economy from coming back, which is about
the election.
I'm sick of it.
Then Trump re tweeting about this issue of
opening schools.
Also what Chuck Woolery said, quote, There
is so much evidence.
Yes.
Scientific evidence that schools should open
this fall.
It's worldwide and it's overwhelming.
But no, we have a medical situation, a global
hundred year pandemic.
And you have a reality TV show host president
amplifying the messages of the former host
of the TV show Love Connection.
And what they are amplifying are messages
that run directly counter to what medical
experts are saying.
The U.S. keeps breaking its own record for
new cases in a single day.
The death toll is around one hundred and forty
thousand.
Remember, Trump said once it would be 60000,
maybe 70000.
Do you get why the world is laughing at us,
but also increasingly crying instead of laughing?
We've handled the virus as close to as badly
as any country out there.
And in the midst of 60 to 70 thousand new
cases a day, a reality TV host, President
Re tweets a game show host, Republican as
if they know more than the medical community.
I told you earlier, the White House has released
what is essentially opposition research on
Dr. Anthony Foushee.
And Trump is instead of standing with the
doctors, standing with Chuck Woolery.
We are a global laughing stock.
And this is why I said earlier, we can't allow
them to turn the next three and a half months
into statues and flags.
This is the red alert failure.
Now, you know, in terms of the list of things
Foushee got wrong and why Trump is increasingly
retweeting Chuck Woolery and not Fouche.
Bouts she got mask's wrong?
That's right.
FOUT she got a symptomatic spread.
Wrong Foushee has corrected himself, but Trump
said in February are 15 cases will soon be
zero.
He hasn't apologized.
He's not admitted fault.
Trump said in February case numbers are going
to go down, not up.
He was wrong.
Trump said in March.
Were we have the virus under control?
We didn't.
Trump said in April.
What about injecting bleach and isopropyl
alcohol?
You get the picture.
So this is very, very dangerous talk.
The mask lists.
Followers are making it worse.
Just look at what's happening in Florida.
Look at what's happening in Arizona, arguably
the two worst places in the world to be right
now.
I don't know what we need to change people's
minds.
Like, do we need video of icy use?
So people see what it is that happens and
what's going on.
Will they understand graphic video, some of
these folks?
I don't know.
But what we know is we've got to remove him.
We have three and a half months to go.
And at this point, Chuck Woolery, Chuck Woolery,
we'll have more about this on these shows.
Instagram page, David Pakman show
on Instagram The David
Pakman Show.